i'm a huge fan of your work
it is awesome to get to talk with you
today um
in your career and i could be wrong
about this but i believe
almost like 99 of the movies you've made
have been you surrounded by men
in an action film uh what was it like
working with this
kick-ass group of women uh and just all
women
one word awesome i mean i just love
sitting back and watching them i mean
karen
she is just outstanding lena the way she
attacks each move
and angela the ferocity if looks could
kill
you're dead and carla she's got that
sweet
gentle way until she gets her hands on
you
yes it was actually quite
mind-blowing working with such an
awesome
all ladies cast uh i'm not going to talk
about spoilers but
in the third hour there's this amazing
slow-motion
tracking shot that is so badass
and i just want to know what was it like
filming that particular sequence
you have to remember that this slow
motion act which is
in the diner you have to you have to
keep your eyes open because
it is done in one shot it's in the
entirety of the diner where we
three the three the librarians
the three sisters are kicking ass and
take no
four sisters are taking everyone down
and
when it was hard because navot
would keep whispering in my ear okay
you're starting this all right and
you're finishing it so we're all
watching you okay
so don't get it wrong i'm like thank you
no pressure
you know because you swing around and it
once you swing well once i turn around
the guns go blazing there is just not
no stop but what it is it was all about
precision
about confidence and laurent our sun
coordinator
they had worked it out like exactly the
timing with the with the camera
they were all moving parts at that time
and it was brilliant it really was
i've never done a shot like that before
that shot is amazing before i run out of
time with you
i'm obviously as you can tell by a
statue behind me a big marvel fan
um what can you tease people about shang
chi and of course
uh working with james cameron on the
avatar sequence
oh shang chi wow um it's
we are so happy that we are having our
first chinese asian superhero
right uh and not just superhero but
super heroines around him as well
and i am a guardian of a mythical
city and these young people they come in
and they have to learn
how to protect what is his history and
to practice not just
this world but the worlds that are
around us from
the demons that are locked away so it's
magic
it's reality so many things happening
and it's
a lot of fun and avatar
james cameron
respect total respect love the guy he's
just creating a new world
i don't even know how to begin to tell
you it's a joy just to sit next to him
and watch
so that's what i do he's the smartest
man in the room
always um thank you so much for your
time and again
it was really cool to talk today good to
see you